welcome all to suffolk's first low
energy showcase
we are extremely excited to bring
together businesses and community
organizations from across the region
sharing one major thing in common the
aim to become carbon neutral
baber and mid-suffolk district councils
have recognized the existence and
reality of the climate emergency and we
have committed to the suffolk wide aim
to become carbon neutral by 2030.
in november the world's attention will
turn to glasgow and cop26 the u.n
climate summit where nations will come
together to discuss what steps we need
to take globally to address the issue of
climate change
this highlights not only the importance
of climate change as a problem but the
significance of doing our part for a
greener society now
and so on a local level we are delighted
to be able to celebrate sustainability
and green energy
in such a way that brings the councils
and communities together
this is the perfect opportunity to
demonstrate our commitment in tackling
climate change
where we can all build build on our
knowledge of green energy and prepare
for a new way of living that enhances an
eco-friendly ethos
thank you everyone i'll now hand over to
councillor morley
thank you council award
suffolk is a hub of great ideas for
clean energy offering real solutions
that can genuinely make a positive
impact towards carbon reduction and will
benefit us both locally and nationally
from solar energy to ground source heat
pumps local energy is already a growing
sector
there is a huge potential to increase
more skilled jobs in the region whilst
also supporting our joint ambition in
developing a cleaner and greener space
to live work and visit
green energy has many benefits
the least of which are offering our
communities a cleaner brighter and more
sustainable future
together we can help businesses and
community groups reduce the impact on
the environment
lower energy costs and contribute to the
fight against climate change
that's what we are here for
and we are pleased to be working with
such forward thinking
partners for this showcase
we hope you enjoy the workshops
throughout the day
learn new things from our expert
speakers and come away from this event
with a positive and practical outlook
on how you can contribute to a
sustainable and carbon neutral future
thank you